Jade brain what are we gonna watch today
sleepwalkers pinky like we always do
I've never seen this one I have no idea
what it's about do you
pinky I am absolutely clueless I I am
all I know I know there's cats in it's
something about cash I think it has a
bad reputation uh you know I just looked
up like so a Stephen King movie you've
got about a 85% chance it's kind of bad
reputation but it's one of those things
worse just serve like I think it's bad I
think it's not supposed to be good so we
have no clue of this at all it's done
Cindy Pinkett Sydney Pinkett who's Cindy
Pickett I don't know this was
sleepwalkers and written by step hen no
shut up kind every time I see a Columbia
logo I want to hear the Ghostbusters me
you think
[Music]
is this supposed to be a dark comedy no
I'm just totally on board yes gives new
meaning to the cat poster hang in there
[Laughter]
well we can't act like the fake-out it's
gonna be a cat okay that was cool this
is not creepy it's funny it's kind of
adorable
one day I'll buy a shirt gotta practice
my alphabet that's also in his blood the
intermission not really sure why we keep
popcorn up there on top of the machine
it's pretty fucking stupid how'd you
like just a cup of slosh keep magic
getting a coke slush and it literally
just looks like slow what would your
girlfriend say if you gave the popcorn
girl the ride home no girlfriend my
boyfriend wouldn't have a problem it's
my son officer
so I said Cersei and Jaime I was close
so their mother and Sons that's fucked
up wait a minute
yeah wait we were worried what are they
she said it's my son officer I'm sorry I
just like fucking what mother and son Oh
Oh like here's this bucket of no
sleepwalkers no I suggest that next time
you keep your hands to yourself mr.
Crawford thank you all for close-up I
won't do it again I thought it was very
sad you know what I think is sad you're
all 30 years
how many times are you gonna keep
failing your fresh mister maybe tell my
shoulder pads more okay everyone in this
school is way too happy like all the
people in the background like Tony's
gonna show me boobs oh really
see I do rubbings two of her boobs
powder or stick on her for losing me so
this is like some Christian abstinence
ad don't have sex because the guy
interested in you might want to suck
yourself and he eat cats which is
symbolic yes you are Charles if you
think you can wiggle out of this this is
blackmail mr. phallus mr. phallus that's
my molested back this one from crazy too
kind of boring just right back to crazy
in a millisecond what day hasn't ended
between the two of us where we're
running with our missing hand through
the woods shouting I'm sorry
it just jumped right back into totally
fucking insane right when we were
starting to guess as a little doll it's
just like fuck you know
come give a cat in the color hairpin
turns high-risk moves with my kitty by
my side breaker breaker 90 this is Pussy
Galore chasing a van yeah he's like one
of those cops from for ebony Falls like
those two really dumb cops looking at me
fucking cat what is it Chloe
get out at least good sniffer map about
boy Jimmy further down the well and you
just laughed at him shit close your won
me motherfucker we don't help we laugh
and judge that's the only reason the
cats are pissed if these guys like wait
there's a creature on this planet more
douchey than we are
he didn't like Clovis it was like he was
scared of me scared of a cat Frank we
don't have a cat tonight deputy had a
cat
what kind of deputy carries a cat I
don't know Mom it's really weird this
whole town is really weird okay maybe we
picked the wrong place to move to
there's a hundred cats here and even the
goddamn cops have cats should they have
dogs mom fucking dogs what kind of
police department is cats if why we've
gone to Maine Pennywise city could've
set us up we caught a cat sound effect
seriously it's always the same like
three or four cats on the facts like in
every movie yeah no no fuck you Stephen
King you've ruined sex for us he weird
the boy's best friend is his mother
hungry apparently a boy's best fuck is I
was thinking Lovers Lane but sure the
cemetery's fine well those are the
cemetery or serial killer cliff this is
where I buried all my victims and then
she kills him what a twist
would be awesome their gum dunny with
this Becker and his an he's a one-ball
man and he's off to the road you ever
see like I was just totally gotten past
the fact they saw this alien nightmare
creature that could ride at the speed of
light is like hey girl with you get
older do do do do do do now rub me like
one of your tombstones Jack you were
talking about Tonya yeah what slender
clothes Casey are you doing say dark
comedy huh it's clearly not harm the
Bandit every movie should just cut back
to this guy singing is a little song and
like the biggest crazy escapes Buford T
kitten it's amazing
you sure change indirectness cuz this
seems very much like Maximum Overdrive
have you shoot him you only make a man
come out punch I'm trying to score these
cats yeah you just saw hundred of them
that's by far the biggest plot hole of
this movie I be I was with it fine until
after there Freddie I am taking the rap
on this this this movie's fucking crazy
I don't part of this love
he's just washed his hands it is I'm not
taking the rap for this there were
parents though a class one assault if
not a curfew Mina they know she managed
to avoid being raped by the bastard yes
okay I'll just take her back to my place
and chain her to the radiator
I would not destroy little girl needs a
good smack on the butt and if her mom
and daddy won't do it I'll happily
volunteer does he think she's five
phrase glove comes up maybe it was the
win yeah baby sweet all right it's okay
guys do wind it still wind sweet the
wind you know I've missed this kind of
Stephen King corn on the cob aye-aye
I think I'm in love I adore this movie
uh-huh how does this only have 50
percent of Rotten Tomatoes
oh it's less than that is like 12
something like this does this movie no
no this is the masterpiece this is some
of the most gorgeous lee refined garbage
I have ever seen Oh
just watch my pastor the others like
ain't kept my butter down it's enough of
that
[Laughter]
hey remember when this just started with
two people dancing and we just thought
it was like a boyfriend/girlfriend right
yeah that's weird oh this movies getting
boring when this song played again by
the end of it we'd see any yeah this is
kind of dull just then whispering and
talking is just like oh my god I am so
sorry movie I'm sorry I made any
criticism of you at all well that's
obviously the work of the wind King was
high as a kite this had to be the coke
here
well I can't say I expected that
[Laughter]
[Music]
the rules are comedy I haven't had this
much fun since watching that hick die
and Evil Dead - oh my god I love the
shit out of that was line is the best
craziest shit sense Maximum Overdrive
that was their perfect amount of time to
just an hour and a half it ended at just
the right point
just the right amount insanity we really
thought it was gonna be boring like it
was ghosts are crap and get to point and
it just went insane that was almost Sam
Raimi worthy oh I love this movie this
is YouTube movie you do Myka
so good this is what bad movies should
be I'm glad I do nothing going into yeah
Sammy this is so much better oh my god
this may be one of my favorite Stephen
King comes over yes thank you there is
nothing else like so entertaining so
entertaining oh crap I love it I don't
love it I love it
well done Bravo good sir nicely done
oh what a piece of wondrous shit well
watch it again yeah
you